j'ai 23 ans et des fois je me dis que je
sais pas trop apprécier la vie
je pense justement les belles choses
trop à coeur
jusqu'à ce que je manque d'en crever
va être sur le banc
feu ça fait vraiment plaisir de voir
pourquoi parce que tu me plais super
huit ans que moi c'est paris je me suis
engagé dans l'armée
pourquoi tu fais ça je me demande
parfois si j'ai pas vu à l'avance tout
ce qui nous attendait et c'était un
cauchemar
mon seul vrai mérite c'est d'être revenu
vivant
m
il se brouille tout temps dans ma tête
il s'arrête un jour qui s'éteindra je
vois pas comment quelqu'un pourrait
commettre un braquage sans être un
minimum d espérer ça fait un moment que
je fais ça
et les flics ça fait très bien la gueule
que j'ai
[Musique]
c'est que toi qui vas t'on
qu'est ce que vous vous souvenez de la
rencontre avec la personne que vous avez
le plus aimé
ce que vous avez vu en elle
vous avez vous dire voilà
c'est pour ça que je finis sur terre
[Musique]
je me demande parfois si j'ai pas vu à
l'avance tout ce qui nous attendait et
c'était un cauchemar
[Musique]